hello this is Justin with the chess
website and today I'm going to show you
the seven deadliest traps for beginners
in chess so starting off we're going to
show the Petro defense it starts E4 E5
Knight to F3 so we're attacking this
pawn and instead of defending the pawn
black just mirrors us they do the same
exact thing we do and this is very
dangerous because if we take and they
take how we're going to punish this is
we're going to play Queen to
E2 and now if they keep mirroring us and
play Queen to E7 we just take this and
they're not going to be able to take
here because we're going to take their
Queen and be completely winning so after
we play Queen to E2 um black has better
advised to do something like move their
Knight so if they move their
Knights this sets up the Petro trap and
here we play the nasty discovered check
Knight to C6 attacking the queen
attacking the king winning the
game the only um way to deal with it is
to either block with the bishop or queen
or Knight every single one of them is
just bad loses material the Knight is
going to be able to take the queen um if
it lands on E7 and that's going to be
the
game so next is the
Dao um trap so that starts E4 E5 Knight
to F3 very similar start but here
instead of playing Knight to F6 black
plays F6 to try to defend this E5 Pawn
but we don't care we're going to take
this anyway sacrifice the Knight and
after F takes E5 bring our Queen out to
H5 give a check and we're also attacking
this Pawn on E5 which is really
important so if the King goes up we
actually have a very nasty series of
checks where this king is going to be
forced into the corner and um this check
here is going to be disgusting and black
is just in terrible shape and then after
this check if black tries to block it
with G6 we're going to take on E5 with
check and we're actually forking the
king and the Rook so we're going to win
material and the
game um next up is the Noah's Ark trap
this is is a very old trap but it's very
important to know instead of Knight to
F6 we're going to look at Knight to C6
so black tries to defend this pawn and
then Bishop to B5 is the Roy Lopez this
is the oldest opening in the book it's
played so many so many times um and
after A6 Bishop A4
D6 white tries to play D4 and strike in
the center but this is unfortunately not
going to work um because after B5 the
bishop goes to B3 black will take on D4
with the Knight after they take back
they take back and the queen takes this
bishop is in terrible shape and after C5
and the queen moves somewhere C4 this
bishop is trapped and we're just winning
a piece right out of the opening now if
the queen goes to D5 instead all black
has to do is play Bishop to E6 which
defends The Rook which was attacked and
and also defends the mate um and after
this uh a move like C4 here is going to
be winning because the river is
protected moving on let's go to the
fishing pole the fishing pole can start
in a number of ways but the way I'm
going to show is after E4 E5 just like
we've seen before Knight to F3 Knight to
C6 if white just develops the bishop
black brings this Knight out and after
castles black sets up the Trap by
playing Knight to
G4 this Knight on G4 is not very well
placed but it could induce a weakness if
white isn't careful and if white falls
for the Trap they'll play
H3 seemingly natural move attacking the
Knight but we're going to play H5
sacrifice the Knight and after they take
black takes back the Knight has to move
it's under attack and once it moves the
queen goes to the H file and it teams up
with this Rook
um to deliver a Checkmate on the H5 the
next trap is the Siberian trap starts
after E4
C5 D4 this is called the smithm gambits
white is gambiing a pawn so Black's
going to win a pawn but it's actually
black who has the trap in their back
pocket after Knight C6 E6 Queen C7 this
is very similar to the fishing pole
where after White Castles they play
Knight to G4 to try to attack this H2
Pawn potentially team up with this queen
and black has good pressure here and the
trap again is set as soon as white plays
H3 so this move kind of the the key move
in multiple of these traps because it's
a weakening move and it doesn't actually
do that much because here instead of
dealing with this threat black and play
the Brilliance kn
D4 because here the Knight is
controlling the square but the Knight
can't take because the Knight is
overworked it was doing a job it was
controlling H2 from F3 and now it's not
so it needs to stay on F3 controlling H2
otherwise it's going to get checkmated
so after Knight to D4 there's actually
nothing that white can do um it doesn't
just immediately lose material so if
they take here um black is just going to
take the queen and be up material and
win the game so that is the fishing pool
and next is the
kocon so the kocan starts with
C6 and then white plays this system
called the two knights they bring both
of their Knights out um and black takes
in the center white recaptures with
their Knights and after Knight to F6
instead of retreating or taking white
keeps the tension in the center and
plays Queen to E2 protecting that Knight
and after a move like Knight to D7 the
Trap has been set we utilize this queen
on E2 controlling this e file by playing
Knight to
D6 Checkmate in six moves because this
Pawn is pinned it cannot take the
knights and the King can't move it's
smed by its own pieces a beautiful
Checkmate and only six
moves lastly
I'm going to show you the Milner Barry
Gambit that starts after the French
defense which is E6 and then D4 D5 E5
this is the advanced variation white is
advancing past black and after C5 C3
Black's plan is to attack this D4 Square
so they go about this by bringing their
Queen and their Knight to attack the
square and white is going to say all
right you can go ahead and have this
Pawn on D4 you can go ahead and take it
but this is exactly what white wants and
after Knight takes D4 Queen takes D4 it
sets up the devastating Bishop B5
check discover check winning the queen
and the game so this has been the seven
deadliest traps for beginners thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video